oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
elle a eu dans ce dernier week end avant
noël un samedi de manifestations contre
le projet de loi sur la sécurité globale
plus timide que les semaines passent et
on a manifesté dans plusieurs villes et
gilet jaune ont bravé l'interdiction de
se rassembler et ils étaient quelques
centaines devant le conseil d'état
très encadrée d'ailleurs par les forces
de l'ordre avant de prendre la direction
du pont des arts nous ferons un point
dans ce journal
nos voisins européens prévoient ti d'un
noël moins flexibles que chez nous le
royaume uni prévoit dès demain d'euros
confiné londres et le sud-est du pays
l'état libre confine à partir de lundi
ailleurs en europe l'objectif est clair
éviter une troisième vague en janvier de
son côté la suède serre la vis et change
de stratégie point complet dans ce
journal
les tensions en république
centrafricaine à près d'une semaine des
élections générales le gouvernement
accuse l'ex président renversé en 2013
françois bozizé d'une tentative de coup
d'état plusieurs groupes armés qui le
soutiennent remettent en cause l'accord
de paix de khartoum signe en 2019
ils ont formé une coalition et mène une
offensive dans l'ouest du pays à l'onu à
déployer des casques bleus et appelle à
la retenue champ
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france on a manifesté
dans plusieurs villes
aujourd'hui à paris également une
mobilisation c'est vrai plus timide que
les précédentes mais sans violence gilet
jaune toujours interdit de manifester
ont lancé une marche parapluie à la main
on soutient moon
cette manifestante interpellé samedi
dernier le point sur ce rassemblement
qui est terminé et qui s'est déroulé
sans heurt avec notre reporter estelle
fâchent
il aura fallu une petite heure au
cortège à del gilet jaune pour rejoindre
son lieu de dispersion ici où je me
trouve à proximité de la station louvre
rivoli et du pont des arts un petit peu
plus tôt plusieurs centaines de gilets
jaunes ont répondu présent au rendez
vous qui avait été donné à 14h devant le
conseil d'état des gilet jaune qui pour
certains sont venus un muni d'un
parapluie multicolores en soutien à moon
cette manifestante interpellé samedi
dernier lors de la manifestation contre
la loi sécurité globale elle est accusée
d'avoir déclenché des violences avec son
parapluie du côté des revendications et
bien il ya bien sûr le refus de la loi
sécurité a global lui aussi des
revendications qui ont fait le mouvement
à des gilet jaune à savoir à plus de
justice fiscale plus de justice sociale
je vous propose d'écouter certains
manifestants le mot d'ordre plus voir la
même chose depuis le début du social
les gens qui sont deux heures qui ne
devrait pas le net on attend que
monsieur max faso ce qui nous a dit
c'est bien d'en accueillir les gens en
disant on fait un discours et mais rien
ne change
donc aujourd'hui ben on attend que le
jour qui nous donne des réponses
demandées élite en fioul donnera pas on
sera tous loire là pour l'embêter tant
qu'on aura un pouvoir qui ne sera pas
légitime et représentatifs de la
majorité de la population
je voudrais tous les samedis dire merde
à monsieur macro même s'il me suis fait
embarquer la semaine dernière avec mon
mégaphone en queue de cortège parce que
je chantais on est là on est là même si
mac on ne veut pas tout ça mais je
continuerai au contraire plus il y aura
une répression contre les filets jaunes
plus je serai motivé on est là contre la
loi sécurité globale l'article 24 on
n'en veut pas dans sa totalité
de toute façon la coupe est pleine je
crois que les français commencent à
s'éveiller la crise sanitaire
une mascarade dans le sens où elle
permet de détruire
tous les fondamentaux de la constitution
notre liberté de circuler de vivre de
sourire voilà pour les revendications
initialement léger les jaunes avaient
prévu ce qu'ils ont appelé la marche des
pouvoirs c'est à dire qu'ils entendaient
déambuler dans les rues de la capitale à
proximité de lieux symboliques comme le
sénat l'assemblée nationale ou encore à
matignon mais ce parcours a été retoqué
par la préfecture de police en raison
notamment de risques de troubles à
l'ordre public
de leur côté alléger les jeunes hommes
ont annoncé leur intention de réitérer
leur action samedi prochain on en parle
tout de suite de cette journée de
mobilisation avec jean-pierre colombiès
et les porte-parole de l'union nationale
des policiers d'indépendants bonsoir
merci à d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france on l'a vu que cette journée
elle s'est très bien déroulé il n'y a
pas eu de art
pas de débordement non plus une bonne
nouvelle pour les forces de l'ordre
bonsoir oui c'est une bonne nouvelle
dans la mesure où il n'y a pas
d'affrontements il n'y a pas de blessés
de part et d'autre quelques côté que ce
soit maintenant faut pas trop se faire
d'illusions et nous sommes à la veille
des fêtes de fin d'année il ya peut-être
une forme de trêve où je dirais
d'assouplissement des volontés de
s'exprimer il faut espérer que ce soit
pas le calme avant la tempête tout
simplement il faut pas se tromper les
revendications sont toujours là la
colère elle est là elle est existante
elle et elle est sous jacente à un
climat très anxiogène très dur je crois
qu'il faut se garder de tout satisfecit
prématuré de quelque côté que ce soit il
ya un beauvau de la sécurité qui
s'annonce pour le mois de janvier
l'objectif c'est pour l'exécutif le
gouvernement de regagner la confiance
des forces de l'ordre
on parle beaucoup de défiance d'ailleurs
entre les deux parties est ce que vous
confirmez et comment est-ce qu'on peut
mesurer cette défiance
comment voulez vous que l'on croit à une
énième neame rassemblement une énième
discussion qui ne repose pas sur quoi
que ce soit de je dirais de crédible les
revendications des syndicats de police
et pas simplement des syndicats et des
policiers de la base va bien au delà
quand on voit bien qu une fois de plus
vous est organisé pour calmer le jeu il
y a une base policière qui est parfaite
qui est très mécontente qui est très
remonté il faut pas ne faut pas s'y
tromper et les policiers dans leur
ensemble bien conscience que ce boulot
est fait pour calmer le jeu pour calmer
des esprits mais pas grand monde n'y
croit il est quand même surprenant on
voit moins que quelques quelqu'un
qu'elle cache quelque chose au président
m mais surprenant qu'on ait l'idée ceux
de ce nouveau alors même que des
revendications existe depuis des années
qu'on a édité un livre blanc
considérable on assortiment
véritablement que c'est un ce sont des
faux semblants que c'est un nuage de
fumée pour dissimuler cacher et à deux
des revendications à une colère réel des
policiers de base pour vraiment vraiment
pas s'y tromper personne ne croit
vraiment à ce beau mot une fois très
clair et pour revenir à la semaine
passée qui c'est bon il n'y a pas eu
vraiment une violence pas eu de casse
lors de du 3e samedi une manifestation
en tout cas gérald darmanin milices de
l'intérieur il a beaucoup twitter et
twittait le nombre d'interpellations
il a tweeté 142 interpellations et
encadrement du cortège qui a permis donc
de protéger les commerçants ce chiffre
il est il est remis en cause parce que
142 interpellations ont la question qui
se pose c'est de savoir si elle est
vraiment des black blocks parmi ces
interpellés des profils radicaux ou bien
si c'était des manifestants votre avis
là-dessus
vous savez communiquer par voie de suite
c'est la mode c'est la façon actuelle
aujourd'hui comme tous les politiques de
communiquer vis-à-vis de l'opinion
publique ou vis-à-vis de de la police ou
des manifestants au mans face à être sa
vie des limites
les interpellations dont on a tant parlé
des bouches quasiment aucune
condamnation et pour cause c'est qu'on
n'est pas capable dans ce pays encore de
faire la différence entre des
interventions sur le terrain et la
rédaction à l'établissement de
procédures judiciaires qui tiennent tout
simplement la route on perd de vue dans
ce pays que le premier et dernier
interlocuteur des policiers ce sont les
magistrats
si vous leur proposez des
interpellations sans motif concret de
mise en garde à vue bien ça ne peut
déboucher que sur disque sur
délibération et une absence totale de
condamnations
on ne peut pas inventer des délits qui
n'ont pas été commis et quand bien même
ils ont été commis il faut le prouver
tout simplement donc tout ça est à
relativiser
on a vu des interpellations
effectivement faut se poser la question
de savoir si elle était préventive est
justifié au-delà de ça tout est une
question de sémantique pardon et de
prise de parole qui est repose qui ne
repose pas sur grand chose de concret il
faut le dire
et la polémique qui enfle sur qui a été
interpellé des manifestants ou vient
réellement des profils voilà radicaux
vous savez un criminologue disait il a
tout à fait raison que lorsque le
ministère de l'intérieur communique sur
le nombre d'interpellations ou le nombre
d'interventions il transfère quant aux
températures c'est exactement ça je
mentirais pas un mot de ce qu'il a de ce
que cette personne a dit ça n'enlève pas
si vous voulez l'analyse qui devrait
présupposés à tout ça qui est la raison
de la colère qui est la raison de cette
mobilisation permanente à laquelle on
assiste depuis plusieurs années
maintenant et face à laquelle on ne pose
que des forces de l'ordre forces de
l'ordre que l'on stigmatise dans leurs
actions d'un côté comme de l'autre et il
faut sortir de sa part quelques voix
qu'il soit mais par une voie politique
c'est fondamental
il y à un dialogue social à avoir il
faut effectivement changé le changer de
braquet que ce soit vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique ou de même vis-à-vis
des policiers et ça n'est pas
systématiquement en se contentant de se
satisfaire de nombre d'interpellations
flynn samedi qu'on va sortir de cette
crise d'ailleurs on n'a jamais vu ça je
ne pense pas que les plus anciens des
journalistes ou les politologues les
plus anciens et vu une crise aussi
longue s'installer dans un pays comme la
france fait en gros on est un petit peu
dans une gestion de l'entente sur les
faits
de violences policières les accusations
de racisme systémique au sein des forces
de l'ordre
votre avis là-dessus et comment
justement on lutte contre des
comportements qui sont a priori isolée
au sein des forces de l'ordre
vous vous apporter la réponse aux propos
question parlait d'un racisme systémique
systématique pour ça comme on veut et
une là encore est vraiment c'est de la
phraséologie c'est c'est de la
rhétorique de francs ça te dépose ça
débouchera sur rien c'est même dangereux
dangereux de faire croire que la police
dans son ensemble était une institution
raciste enfin suffit de regarder je
suppose que vous avez vous aussi dans la
rue vous voyez bien que les patrouilles
de police sont constituées de
fonctionnaires de toutes origines de
toutes couleurs et on veut on peut
difficilement mettre sur le dos de
l'institution total des actes
individuels qui sont je le rappelle faut
quand même rappeler l'objet qui font
l'objet de sanctions je ne dis pas que
tout est parfait dans le meilleur des
mondes pas du tout mais ne jetons pas le
bébé avec l'eau du bain c'est dangereux
c'est très dangereux de se donner c'est
s'installer comme l'a fait le président
une ambiguïté sur ce sujet là la
passerelle qui l'a annoncée de
dénonciations sur l'igpn d'abord elle
existe déjà et ça laisse entendre que
healy a véritablement un problème de
fond au sein de la police nationale ce
qui est dangereux mais dangereux pas
simplement pour les policiers mais même
pour la démocratie
si vous déstabiliser une institution
comme la police la justice avec tous les
défauts qu'elle peut avoir je le précise
vous mettez en danger l'équilibré même
de la démocratie tout simplement merci
beaucoup à vous jean pierre colombiès un
porte-parole de l'union nationale des
policiers d'indépendants merci et un
retour aux sources pour les gilet jaune
aujourd'hui cela s'est passé du côté du
péage de saint-arnoult de 10h à 13h au
coup d'envoi
bien évidemment du départ des vacances
il
du départ en vacances ils ont créé des
passages gratuits pour les
automobilistes il s'agit du plus grand
péage d'europe sur place la gendarmerie
était présente tout s'est déroulé dans
le calme
on va écouter quelques réactions dont
celle du gilet jaune faouzi lellouche
alors on est venu au péage de
saint-arnoult pour rendre la gratuité
aux gens qui utilisent les usagers de
l'autoroute
parce que les autoroutes leur
appartiennent depuis longtemps elles
sont payées et voilà c'est un vrai
pouvoir d'achat donc qu'ils garderont
dans leur poche tout simplement voilà et
je pense que c'est un beau petit cadeau
pour les fêtes
il ya beaucoup de gens qui voyagent qui
se réunissent en famille bah voilà tous
les gens qui arrivent sur l'île de
france ils vont le trouver gratuit c'est
le plus grand d'europe et c'est un bon
signe à savoir que les gilet jaune ils
sont toujours là où on demande au peuple
français de nous donner un coup de main
pour mettre un gros coup d'arrêt à ces
termes gouvernementales avant vous
pouvez le pouvoir d'achat et notre
dignité en tant que route et de dignité
de babel pas que le peuple va retrouver
sa dignité et procède à cet instant
fallait que nous ça va être dur délicat
il a certains qui vont simplement plus
rien à manger des pâtes mais à mon avis
pour le bien de nos enfants c'est rien
ça on est prêt à manger les rémois de
pâques pour nous enfants pas tout seul à
la base pour nos enfants
d'autres rassemblements aujourd'hui pour
gueye camara le jeune homme avait été
tué dans la ville d'epinay sur seine
alors qu'ils se trouvaient tous volant
de sa voiture la famille réclame une
enquête approfondie alors qu'un non lieu
avait été rendue au mois d'août 2010 9
une version remise en cause par ses
proches qui ont fait appel une décision
doit être rendue le 21 janvier prochain
des comptes à ces réactions sur place
recueillis par luc un tueur
que le 21 janvier il n'y a pas d'espoir
on ira soit un bon dieu et donc il est
important de le dire que on n'ira pas
sur un haut lieu c'est l'état la justice
française qui a annoncé qu'il va
annoncer un non lieu mais le combat
camara on lira pas son nom de grâce
qu'on connaît la vérité on demande la
justice parce qu'on connaît très bien la
vérité et mon petit fai a gagné n'avait
pas à mourir ce jour là et aujourd'hui
la l'état et la justice protège des
criminels on est là pour exprimer
réaffirmé le soutien de la municipalité
de chant au travail que mène ce
collectif justice pour gagner je sais
des cambrésiens dans les tic en plaisir
et on partage le sentiment d'injustice
qui exprime la famille les proches et
tous ceux qui les accompagnent de la
famille camara
donc on les a soutenus depuis le début
et on continue de réaffirmer notre
solidarité avec eux c'est pour ça qu'on
est là honorer la mémoire pour expliquer
aux gens en fait que
celui qui est mort ce n'était pas un
délinquant et que en france y est une
histoire de la police et une histoire
sur ces policiers qui peuvent tuer en
toute impunité dans nos quartiers
populaires mais sur le front de la
pandémie des nouvelles mesures de
restriction en europe comme au royaume
uni en beaucoup ont reconquis une dès
demain à londres et dans le sud est de
l'angleterre bord et johnson chef du
gouvernement a même évoqué une nouvelle
souche du virus pas plus mortelle mais
qui se transmettrait plus facilement à
selon lui et puis la suède elle faisait
jusqu'ici cavalier seul dans sa
stratégie face au co vie 19
elle semble aujourd'hui contrainte de
modifier ses plans elle recommande
désormais le port du masque à ses
habitants et le pays augmente même son
budget militaire vous allez voir
pourquoi la réponse avec hélène
masculine le ministère suédois de la
défense prévoit une hausse importante de
son budget pour les quatre prochaines
années
en cause selon stockholm la russie et
l'instabilité l'attend en europe de
l'est et dans le caucase
c'est à cause de la nouvelle situation
sécuritaire notamment compte tenu de
l'agression russe envers la géorgie
l'annexion de la cré mais le conflit en
ukraine des activités en biélorussie la
mise à niveau des capacités militaires
russes d exercice complexe dans la
région de l'arctique et de la mer
baltique
nous voyons une nouvelle conjoncture
sécuritaire et ils sont prêts à utiliser
la force militaire pour remplir des
objectifs politiques s'en faut le faire
pour les deux colosses une hausse des
dépenses militaires tandis que la suède
peine à lutter contre la pandémie
avec une mortalité jusqu'à dix fois
supérieur à ses voisins nordiques et le
pays manque cruellement de moyens pour
faire face au co vie de 19,1 des
biguines d'espagne mais dès le début de
cette pandémie la suède n'avait pas
assez de lits d'hospitalisation
bien sûr cet argent aurait dû être les
lieux utilisés dans ce domaine comme
dans d'autres tels les écoles la santé
publique
l'intégration des migrants etc
le niveau de contamination ne diminue
pas dans le pays
le royaume se trouve en grandes
difficultés pour faire face à cette
seconde vague le roi de suède lui même a
fait cette déclaration sentencieuse
d'hier je crois que nous avons échoué
et sachez que le premier ministre
israélien benyamin nétanyahou s'est fait
vacciner avec le remède développé par
pfizer biotech ce qui lance la campagne
de vaccination en israël à qui déplore
un peu plus de 3000 morts depuis le
début de la pandémie ch
et puis c'est le deuxième foyer de
contamination de coronavirus au monde
l'inde compte plus de 10 millions de cas
aujourd'hui
un chiffre record alors que les pays et
dans la tente de débuter là aussi une
campagne de vaccination importante en
2021 amaya s'oublie avec plus de 10
millions de cas de coronavirus confirmé
l'inde est le deuxième pays le plus
touché au monde dans le terme de
contamination selon le ministère de la
santé plus de 25 mille cas ont été
recensés ces dernières 24 heures même si
les chiffres sont nettement inférieurs à
ceux enregistrés il ya trois mois
certains habitants inquiet appelle à
respecter les mesures prises par le
gouvernement
d'autres sont dans l'attenté d'un vaccin
pour que ça n'augmente pas au cours de
la nouvelle année nous devrions essayer
de respecter les règles et les
directives qui nous ont été données
au lieu de cela les gens font ce qu'ils
veulent
j'attends avec impatience le vaccin
parce que le vaccin est vraiment
nécessaire la situation est en train de
devenir incontrôlable
malgré un bilan total de 145 1136 décès
annoncés ce samedi
l'expert gouvernementale docteur randy
buleria se veut rassurant sur les mois à
venir si nous pouvons maintenir notre
tendance à la baisse au cours des deux
ou trois prochains mois nous devrions
être en mesure de lancer le programme de
vaccination et de commencer à nous
éloigner de la pandémie
l'espoir donc d'une campagne de
vaccination pour enrayer la crise
sanitaire
à l'heure actuelle trois laboratoires
ont demandé des autorisations pour
déployer d'urgence leurs remèdes en inde
les autorités ont identifié 300 millions
de personnes à vacciner en priorité le
pays qui connaît une récession sans
précédent pour la première fois de son
histoire tant à assouplir malgré tout
les règles imposées fin mars bureaux
magasins restaurants et bars ont rouvert
de même que les services ferroviaires
les écoles en revanche elle reste fermée
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
l approche des élections présidentielle
et législatives du 27 décembre en
république centrafricaine la situation
est plus que jamais tendue là bas les
casques bleus sont intervenus dans
l'ouest du pays après la menace de
groupes armés le pouvoir en place dit
craindre un coup d'état de l'ancien
président françois bozizé renversé en
2013 ont fait le point avec pierre
favier verdu
c'est par la voix de son porte parole
antonio guterres est ce que l'onu a
appelé ce vendredi à la cessation des
hostilités en centrafrique
et pour cause l approche du scrutin
présidentiel les trois principaux
groupes armés du pays viennent
d'annoncer leur fusion et la création
d'une coalition
celle ci devrait réunir le 3r groupe qui
protège la communauté peule
le mpc qui rassemble des combattants
musulmans et les antis bakala composé à
la base de paysans selon des sources
humanitaires
cette coalition armée s'est emparé de
plusieurs axes stratégiques autour de
bangui désormais menacé par un blocus à
distance pour le gouvernement
as cette manoeuvre est à mettre au
crédit de françois bozizé président
centrafricain de 2003 à 2013
alors je vous parle monsieur françois
bozizé yangouvonda a quitté la ville de
bossangoa où il s'était retranché et se
trouve actuellement aux abords de la
ville de bossembélé avec l'intention
manifeste de marché avec ses hommes sur
bangui il s'agit manifestement d'une
tentative de coup d'état que le
gouvernement tient à dénoncer en cette
période électorale où le gouvernement
cherche à consolider les acquis
démocratiques à travers les prochaines
consultations pour tenter d'apaiser les
tensions les casques bleus se sont
déployés dans l'ouest du pays ce
vendredi la dîmière monteiro porte
parole de la force onusienne a tenté
dans un communiqué de justifier ce
déploiement
la minustah a déployé vendredi des
forces à bossembélé et à bossembélé deux
localités de la préfecture de l'ombella
m'poko cible d'attaqués menées par des
éléments armés du 3ème du mpc et des
antilles ballack a depuis 2013 la
situation est particulièrement tendue en
centrafrique notamment après les
affrontements entre groupes armés de
différentes confessions religieuses qui
ont coûté la vie à plusieurs milliers de
personnes
alors le calme semble être revenu depuis
le début du week-end c'est en coulisses
que les troubles pourraient se faire de
plus en plus sentir
si les candidats continuent leur
campagne certains acteurs politiques se
posent des questions quant à la tenue
même des scrutins et nous sommes avec
cassano s'il est président de l'institut
international de gestion à des conflits
chien
bonsoir à vous remercier d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france est ce
qu'il faut craindre réellement une
tentative de coup d'état en centrafrique
oui tout à fait il faut la craindre
parce que nous savons comment les choses
se passent et malheureusement comment ça
finit à la centrafrique est un pays qui
a connu la guerre avec des conséquences
énormes pour la population et donc on
doit les innovations aucun effort ou
enrayer la vague de violence qui démarre
avec une coalition hétéroclite à deux
fois mais sans ses dires cookies et
elles s'étaient opposés et qui
aujourd'hui se mettent ensemble pour
mettre en péril la démocratie le débat
ça la vie il faut qu'il se fasse une
bande démocratique
s'il ya des conditions c'est dans les
unes qui font les exposés mais pas en
temps pour prendre des armes
nous avons travaillé dans ce pays nous
avons vu comment le vih ou père voilà
pourquoi je pense que il voit absolument
être qu'il a à tous les points de vue et
anticiper avec cette dynamique de
violence
vous savez qu'il y a un nom qui circule
soupçonné d'être derrière ces tentatives
de déstabilisation il s'agit de françois
bozizé l'ancien président renversé en
2013 on le rappelle par les ex c'est les
cas de michel d'auto jah on l'a entendu
dans le sujet les groupes armés qui
s'organise parmi ces groupes armés et à
des milices anti ballack à qui serait
proche de françois bozizé qui faut-il
penser de tout cela c'est quelque chose
qu'ils aient regrettable parce qu'on
sait l'opposition aujourd'hui qui peut
l'être et monsieur touadéra et n'empêche
que s'il bozizé s'impliquer dans cette
dynamique à cette fois regrettable parce
qu'il a dit a fait un coup d'état
et aujourd'hui il est arrivé souvenez
vous quand il a envie dans son trafic
je pense que le média toit des accords a
dû déclencher une opération qu'ils
soient arrêtés ce qui n'a pas été fait
je pense dans un esprit d'apaisement et
aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que ce soit
une bonne chose que je te reposer plus
se retrouver dans des situations d'une
nouvelle rébellion
j'espère en tout cas que le bon sens va
revenir en france un trafic vous que le
débat démocratique
le dessus parce que si les mêmes faits
se reproduisent ce serait dommage et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui avec à l'alliance
entre les antilles baraka est tel qu'on
peut le dire à brancher bozizé et
laisser les cas les anciens syndicats
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour le
peuple centrafricain et il est important
qu'un la louve à ce passeport mobilité
et pour que les uns les autres de gros
viennent à de bons sentiments et vous
ressentez vraiment dans le combat
démocratique
c'est peut-être vrai aussi que sa
candidature soit ait refusé ou pas là la
cour constitionnelle dessus des raisons
qui ont été évoquées ce sont pas des
raisons farfelues mais je pense qu'il a
joué le jeu pratiqué à 7 et est
aujourd'hui c'est triste de constater
que on risque de le voir encore dans une
rébellion
j'espère que ça va pas aller loin et que
l'opposition de la rue jusqu'à et des
forces de défenses et en afrique elle va
faire en sorte que les gens les joutes
mort de bunny radon sentiments pour
éviter surtout à la population parce que
n'oubliez pas c'est la population sans
marquer aucun cas la première victime
est il important de la préserver et
d'arrêter cette qu'elle éveille
dynamique de violence
alors comment en est on arrivé là depuis
la transition l'élection de faustin
archange touadéra la tête du pays
c'est vrai vous faisiez allusion à la
minurcat la mission onusienne qui est
présente en république centrafricaine
depuis des années après la guerre civile
comment est-ce qu'on en arrive là
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya des groupes
armés qui occupent encore les deux tiers
du territoire centrafricain
vous savez les spirales convenant au
niveau de la peine c'est que la paix une
démarche similaire il ya un accord de
paix la mise à prix est délicate parce
que comme népalais qui l'idée force vers
que l'armée centrafricaine a commencé à
se reconstruire qu'en partant
négociations quand vous êtes
désavantagés sur le plan de la france
vous n'avez pas les mêmes éléments
et donc aujourd'hui et d'ancenis d'état
pendant mes lampes à appliquer
concrètement et je pense que le choix
d'une maison trois d'hier a été de ne
pas fait la guerre pour amener la paix
certains critiques que ce choix c'est un
temps damien on peut pas faire la guerre
pour amener la paix est donc aujourd'hui
à l'accord qui a été signé
la mise en oeuvre n'a pas été sincère de
bas ces deux acteurs et nous avons les
conséquences aujourd'hui
parce que faut pas oublier que la guerre
est aussi une vente parce que la guerre
était arrivée ces terres se sont
enrichis ont développé des affaires et
la paix et quelque chose médias leur
empêcher les empêcher d'accéder à ces
pièces et donc anti gang à la femme on
n'y est pas totalement et je te bases
que le cas l'appétit du caire est
quelque chose qui est fondamentalement
en anglais mais aussi il faut le
connaître il ya des positions politiques
parce que quand c'est la politique
chacun a envie d'être à la place jacques
soulié le bas parce que c'est un jeu
politique il y est normale mais qu'il
faut aider les âmes démocratique
or aujourd'hui beaucoup de tartans coeur
se sont accumulés malheureusement alors
que nous sommes là dans la dynamique et
d'apaisement les coeurs des amas de
coeur voilà pourquoi je pense que après
l'acte ans malgré les efforts fait de
parler d'autres nous sont entre 1 mois
mais la paix n'est pas totale en
centrafrique mais il ya un effort
considérable qui est fait si nous avons
aujourd'hui une élection présidentielle
avec toi ex président qui se présentait
merci monsieur bozizé et il ne faudrait
pas la proportionnelle il ya quand même
assez imposant qui est candidate
le président sortant dont celle déjà une
vitalité démocratique
et ça c'est quelque chose d'assez
particulier qu'il faut sur vinassan
parfaite
voilà à quoi je pense qu'il faut
continuer dans cette dynamique préserver
les élections pour qu'un candidat comme
ta sorte et le 27 décembre pour conduire
a conçu la paix pour conclure et
l'accord de cartoon signé en 2019 avec
la fille du soudan et de la russie
beaucoup le jugent cet accord pas
suffisamment inclusif et vous pensez que
c'est le cas non je ne pense pas que ce
soit le cas c'est d'accord qu'il est
tellement mauvais remède accord mais
pertinent quoique omar hilale bien leur
vocation les conditions de mes
semblables ce qui n'est pas mauvais il
est bon mais la mise en oeuvre n'a pas
été et pour les ducasses à tous les
coins de rue parce qu'avec beaucoup de
blocages et cet accord là je pense qu'il
est particulier et novateurs dans un
brasier
la mise en moule est difficile quand
vous savez la négociation pour la paix
vous savez que c'est une oeuvre de
longue haleine et il faut avoir de la
patience
donc ce n'est pas en deux jours que les
choses se font il faut persévérer
pourquoi les gens à revenir à la raison
c'est ce que nous espérons pouvoir merci
beaucoup à vous quelques fans ou si je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
l'institut international de gestion des
conflits et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver en direct dans 30 minutes pour
une nouvelle édition rester avec nous
sur rtl
[Musique]
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas la densité brut
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre la
population un territoire qui est porteur
date de causalité une explication mais
des densités un grain si j'ose dire
d'appartement il ya des chaînes de
contagion dit zoto à l'intérieur
rassemblement du milieu familial parce
que on a des familles qui vivre à trois
générations et c'est tout